Netflix Amazon Hulu a theater near you
the modern film fan has more choices
than ever to help you sort through them
all we've taken a hard look at this
year's most critically acclaimed
features and assembled a list of best
bets here's some standouts of what
Hollywood had to offer in the first half
of 2016
Captain America Civil War Captain
America Civil War rounded up a heavy
assortment of Marvel Cinematic Universe
favorites and some highly anticipated
new faces the result is a thrilling
action-packed adventure of superhero
spectacle that even the most anti comic
book film fan might enjoy the which it's
hard to find a horror movie with enough
faith in its audience to take things
slow and get weird
the which-which unspools in a spooky
thicket of woods in 17th century New
England follows a familiar path but it's
director Robert Eggers flair for imagery
that makes the witch so creepily
compelling 10 Cloverfield Lane 10
Cloverfield Lane uses 2008 s Cloverfield
as a launch pad for the story of a woman
played by Mary Elizabeth Winstead who
flees a busted engagement only to run
into disaster she ends up locked in an
underground shelter by a man played by
an unhinged John Goodman who insists the
earth is under attack is he a hero or a
psycho killer the nice guys writer
director Shane Black as the king of
action comedy getting a start by writing
the original lethal weapon back in 1987
do you really want to jump do you wanna
the nice guy's a lower key buddy cop
comedy starring Ryan Gosling and Russel
Crowe as partners in 70s la Cruz that
black is back and he hasn't lost his
gifts greenroom viewers are plunged into
the hellish ordeal experienced by a punk
band who attract the bloodthirsty ire of
some murderous neo-nazi skinheads did we
mention that Patrick Stewart is the
homicidal owner of the club with a band
is trapped starring the late Anton
Yelchin Green Room is equal parts smart
and nasty and one of the more sinfully
enjoyable in the efforts of 2016 Hail
Caesar Hail Caesar which stars Josh
Brolin as a studio fixer and Hollywood's
golden age on a mission to solve the
disappearance of a dopey movie star
played by George Clooney who's been
drugged and abducted from the set
assembled with the typical Coen Brothers
quark it's some of the most fun we've
had of the movies this year everybody
wants some new cool man with his 1993
cult classic Dazed and Confused Richard
Linklater assembled an insightful look
at High School in the 70s he picked that
thread back up with everybody want some
it offers a look at college life and
packs in a killer era-appropriate
soundtrack featuring classic hits from
cheap trick and Van Halen Deadpool how
do you make a Deadpool movie that
embraces the characters filthy comics
persona while still being broad enough
money to prop up a franchise we still
can't quite believe they pulled it off
but Fox made it work the antihero played
by Ryan Reynolds slashes up bad guys and
breaks the fourth wall with equal
abandoned midnight special director Jeff
Nichols and actor Michael Shannon
perfectly captured modern-day
middle-class dread in 2011's take
shelter the pair reunited in 2016 for
midnight special a movie about a father
racing to protect his son from outside
forces bent on taking advantage of his
seemingly superhuman abilities thanks
for watching subscribe to our YouTube
channel to watch more videos like the
one you just saw and leave us a comment
to let us know what 2016 movie was your
favorite so far